are you ready to experience the crash  bandicoot games again I'm Tony this is a  GameSpot news update and for all the  latest on remakes and remasters be sure  to subscribe  Crash Bandicoot and Sain trilogy  includes the first three games in the  series 1996 is Crash Bandicoot 97's  cortex strikes back and 98s warped  Naughty Dog's original levels are all  back but the gameplay has been totally  rebuilt from the ground up by Vicarious  Visions the insane trilogy will only  cost you 40 bucks and it launches on  June 30th so you don't have much longer  to wait this isn't the first time  Activision has dipped into the remake  well last year saw the release of call  of duty modern warfare remastered  alongside infinite warfare if you want  to see crash back in action you can  check out our perfect run of the very  first level over at GameSpot and for all  the latest on the Bandicoot you're  already in the right place